hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round four of the
ftx crypto cup this is the last one
we'll be covering and then we are on to
round five as round five will be uh
completely action-packed uh it is world
champion magnus crossing versus liam lee
yeah and this game uh
has many ups and downs but in the end it
is the uh well sort of the the pawn
storm that prevails but you'll see what
i mean by this magnus plays knight to f3
he goes for retti opening and we have
knight to f6 we have pawn to g3 magnus
going for the king's indian attack sorry
about that
uh and uh le opens uh replies with pawn
to d5 this is the yugoslav attack
variation the base or rather the king's
indian attack the yugoslav variation
with bishop to g2 c6 now uh and uh
magnus castles with bishop to g4 and now
pawn to h3 bishop h5 and c4 that's not a
c4 c4 challenging the center uh e6 now
as the light core bishop has been set
free
and now pawn to d4 by magnus bishop e7
we have knight to c3 and now uh lake
castles we have knight to e5
uh as magnus still hasn't played the e
pawn so you don't have to worry about
any pins uh just knights to e5 and this
is now a monster night whenever you have
a position your opponent plays knight to
e5 you know that that knight is pretty
much staying there for the rest of the
game or at some point you might capture
this knight and then your opponent will
play f4 put a pawn on f5 control all of
these squares uh but that's not what
happens here actually here now leo goes
for knight the knight after the seven
challenges the knight this way and now
uh there are a couple of uh games that
reach this position but uh magnus plays
c captures on d5 and this is now a new
move so already as of move 10 we have a
completely new game now uh of course uh
uh liam lee captures the knight he is
very happy about this we have d captures
on e5 and now e captures on d5 c
captures on d5 would have been a little
bit safer as uh with the pawn on e6 you
have control over the f5 square
but now you can see that magnus can just
start pushing g for f4 uh even e4 in
some lines so he starts with g4 bishop
to g6 and pawn to f4 already threatening
f5 to win the bishop on g6 we have f5
now
stopping this and the bishop the e3
we have knight to a6 and now comes rook
to c1 we have king to h8 and now
well it's a very very interesting
position but magnus goes for the sort of
uh the best practical chance and that is
knight captures on d5 it's a peace
sacrifice but you get two pawns at least
for it
uh so it's a you know it's it's a fair
trade c captures on d5 queen captures on
the e5 offering a queen trade and now
safest would be something like trading
queens let's say it captures captures
and then you try to find a good move for
black knight to b4 maybe put pressure on
the bishop attack a2 because if you try
to defend the b7 pawn there's just no
good way to do it you can't advance the
pawn as the rook hands you can you can
play this because then the a7 pawn hangs
uh so it's a
tough tough call to make but here le
plays a ponte b6 and here he invites
magnus to play queen captures an a8
which means that he will keep the pawns
on the queen side but he will give up
the exchange which is uh an odd thing to
do to say the least but uh you you've
seen how difficult it was to find a move
after the queen trade so okay magnus
goes for queen captures an a8 queen
captures bishop captures and now rook
captures an a8 and now magnus plays rook
f2d1
which of course makes sense you control
the c file you control the d file you
have some ideas of lifting the rook
but if you guys are interested yes a3
and b4 uh are the engine's favorite um
ideas here even saying that once b4 is
played the position is winning for white
but okay rook after d1 and now king to
g8 let's starts bringing the king into
the game and now pawn to e6 magnus takes
away the f7 square from the black king
bishop the c5 now also if a3 b4 uh black
can never use the c5 square again and
that square is useful for the bishop and
for the knight so here rook to c3 magnus
defends the bishop he would very much
enjoy having his rook on e3 to start
escorting the past e pawn uh we have
rooked the e8 going after the pawn and
now rook to d5 magnus with a little
trick uh as if the pawn on e6 is
captured then he can just trade on c5
for example captures captures and then
win the win material here there is no
defense against this so of course lead
doesn't go for this he goes knight to b4
attacks carlson's rook and now uh magnus
has to make a choice is he interested uh
or maybe he wants to go back this is
also a possibility but the real question
is is he interested in a repetition with
rookie five knight c6 rookie whoops uh
rogue d5 knight to b4 and and so on and
so on so this is one uh question but
this is the third game uh
magnus having the white pieces for the
second time so if he accepts a
repetition here uh he has one more game
with the black pieces and that's uh not
something you want to do so instead
after this knight to b4 move magnus
decides to give back
some material and he plays rook c
captures on c5 not saying if you capture
my rook here i'm just gonna have
i will have one two pieces for the rook
and my position is just much much better
even after rook captures here just king
f2 defending the bishop and if you count
the pawns white is up upon and with a
much more active position uh with
perfect play should be a win for magnus
so instead after rook captures in c5 of
course b captures and c5 is a better
move and now magnus plays rook to d6
defending his pawn on e6 so this is how
uh he uh decided to play it he uh uh
keeps the the e6 pawn alive we have
rooked the c8 now defending the c5 pawn
uh but this doesn't really work for leo
because magnus just placed bishop
captures on c5 this was a bit funny now
of course if rook captures the bishop
then this is checkmate as the pawn
covers f7 so you have to give up the
bishop and this is not checkmate so
after bishop captures on c5 we have a5
by lay and now a3 attacking the knight
here knight to c6 and finally pawn to b4
creating a pass pawn it captures eight
captures we have f captures h captures
and now bishop to e8
and now magnus starts bringing the king
into the game king to f2 we have rook to
b8 and now okay the b4 pawn is attacked
but magnus just continues advancing
those pawns on the king's side pawn to
f5 knight captures on b4 and here magnus
plays g5 and now you have to be very
careful what you play uh moves like
knights to c6 are always useful but here
rook to b5 was played
attacking causes bishop on c5 but this
just completely blunders the game and
i'm pretty sure you know why so feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for magnus while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing that the
back rank has completely been weakened
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is rook to d8 this is
what magnus played and he was in this
position on move 34 that liam resigned
the game uh as there is nothing more to
be done here even though he is up a
piece uh there is no uh way of surviving
this rook capture 78 will be checkmate
you cannot play king to f8 as the bishop
covers this so the bishop cannot be
captured this is just mate in one uh and
other than that you really don't have a
good plan you could play some like h5
try and give back the piece but uh you
know then magnus has just so many pawns
and even uh you can checkmate the black
king right away uh or not not rook to hm
but bishop to e3 uh will be checkmate so
you have to take away the g5 square from
the black king and that's just it so the
bishop you attacked and that you
couldn't grab is the one that you know
uh fools you in the end
uh after rook to d8 uh liam lee resigned
and a wonderful victory for magnus
carlsen and he also went on uh to win uh
the the final game so he wins the the
match by uh
by uh three to one uh drawing the first
two games and winning the the last two
games so a really awesome stuff for
those of you who might have missed the
previous video uh where uh where
pragnanda just uh you know completely
obliterated his opponent here are the
standings uh
after uh four rounds magnus and
pragnanda still undefeated with 12
points each uh follow uh alireza uh
following with eight points levon
arunyan
young sister of duda with four anishi
root for liam with three and uh hans
moken niemann still with zero points uh
we'll see how he does in the last two
rounds so for the uh for the penultimate
round uh we have a big big clash magnus
carlson will be facing alireza firuja
and of course uh young [ __ ] of duda will
take on uh pragnanda so we'll see what
happens in that one uh will magnus and
prague uh meet in the final round uh
with 100 that would be a dream but i
mean of course uh
um
uh
you know i i wish good luck to all
players but that would just i i think
that would be very very good for chess
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys uh enjoyed it uh very nicely done
by magnus i would like to thank johan
claussen raymond rafael uh
ahmad and michael sakarias for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
ftx crypto cup round five uh when it
starts uh so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day